[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist and one time
athlete actually today's topic is
born to run farther
i got my co-host chuck nice check hey
that's right
uh no time maybe
you just joke about athletes when you're
doing stand-up that there you go
there it is and i got gary o'reilly gary
former hey neil
former uh pro pro footballer over in the
uk
giving authenticity to this show
and this topic is all in i mean we're
talking about the bio
mechanics i love that term the concept
the profession
the biomechanics of running and we're
going to talk about
like what what do we need shoes
what are shoes for we spent you know
hundreds of thousands of years without
shoes and all of a sudden
somebody's making money off of selling
you shoes we're gonna talk about running
technique
ancient versus modern uh we're gonna get
all
up in the shoe situation and what it has
to do with running
and especially running far so now since
we don't none of us have any particular
expertise in this we have to
we got to reach in and and do our thing
as we do on star talk
and we go into the the the
the academic pool to find out who's
actually
thought hard and deep about this and who
do we have
dr irene davis irene welcome to star
talk
thanks neil it's great to be here yeah
you're the founding director of the
spaulding
national running center in the
department of
physical medicine and rehabilitation
harvard medical school that sounds like
exactly where athletes
want to go exactly when they're hurt
okay
it also sounds like a place where
everybody there just has to jog
every place from me from meeting to
meeting
no matter what a good example is that
yes you just have to be at a light job
no matter what you do at the national
running center
and you're also professor emeritus at
the in physical therapy at the
university of delaware
so all of this is really important cool
uh pedigree and what we're doing is
we're featuring in an interview that i
conducted
with a best-selling author and runner
chris mcdougall
and we'll be playing clips from that
interview just because he's thought a
lot about this and as a journalist
it's taken him to many places and and we
see the influence of his research on his
own life
and on the people that he studied and
written about
so we'll be featuring clips from that as
this show
proceeds oh by the way irene rumor has
it
you're a barefoot runner yourself
yes um i think everybody should try it
it's a way to kind of free your feet and
get all that sensory input that you're
supposed to have
oh okay we'll get into that i like that
it's not that you have bloody feet from
running on pavement it's sensory input
that's right that's that's that's quite
a euphemism irene i'm just saying
that's such a that's i mean you say it
in in a clinical term
but for thousands of years um
there's a thought in many cultures that
in order to connect with who you are
and where you're from you have to put
your
bare feet into the ground
like that there is something spiritual
and
something connective about that
experience
that has nothing to do with what we're
talking about
so let's get to the bottom of it then so
irene if you look at the evolution of
humans as a species all right we spent
much more time not wearing shoes than
wearing shoes so
are are we living the lives our bodies
have
been adapted to lead oh
you touch on a very good point neil so
that that is the basis of the mismatch
theory of evolution
um and i'm sure that's the thing the
mismatch theory
it's it's definitely a thing
we need brilliant academics to come up
with something called the mismatch
theory i know chuck could come up chuck
that's your theory of evolution
exactly the mismatch theory of evolution
yeah
who knew all right all right so go on
what so what do you have there so so the
mismatch theory of evolution does
basically um hypothesize that we're not
living the lives that our bodies were
adapted for
um and it relates to a lot of different
uh features like the air we breathe
the food we eat our activity level but
clearly the way that we run
so we did evolve to run barefoot
we started running about two million
years ago and the first shoes that were
found
were about 10 000 years old there may
have been some before that
but for the majority of our evolutionary
history we have run
barefoot or in minimal shoes so let's go
straight to my first clip
with author and runner chris mcdougall
and i
asked him to highlight in sort of
biomechanical terms
what changed in our early primate
ancestors
that turned us into runners and was it
just this
sort of nuclear ligament that stabilized
our head
let's check it out everything you need
for like a running animal
is all piled up in human body we have
springy tendons we have this
nuclear ligament we have arches in our
feet which give us lots of recoil energy
we have an achilles tendon excuse me i
have flat feet so just be careful when
you talk about
arches and your feet i'm just just i
just want you to know
before you step someplace where we gotta
fight about it just so you know
all right not trying to single you out
as a walker but
uh the achilles tendon for instance
every runner is always complaining about
their achilles tendon like what's the
first thing that people say hurts oh
it's my achilles
the reason why is because the achilles
tendon plays a huge role
in the running stride and so that's
basically where we started to diverge we
went from being these
walking creatures into the running
creatures as soon as we took on all
these tendons
wait so tell me again where this neck
ligament connect it connects what to
what
yeah so it's a ligament which runs down
between the skull
and the lumbar vertebrae so it basically
connects the back of your skull
to your spine so you look at this pig
and the head's wobbling around
if you wanted to stabilize that head
what would you do you take a piece of
wire
stick it on its skull and just anchor it
to the back of its spine
bam nougal ligament so what's really
weird
is we somehow are enchanted by
bobble head dolls
we have reversed out this
key ligament to who and what we are as
humans and then we have humans with
bobbly heads that's
that that's sad you know head bobbles
around as a baby right
so those bobble heads are like steven j
gould would have a field day with this
kind of stuff you know we've you know
turned the baby into something cute but
babies because they haven't stabilized
yet they got the bobbleheads
yeah just to flesh out that reference
stephen j gould was one of the early
anthropologists biological
anthropologists to
suggest that we think babies are cute
because they have these huge eyes and
huge head relative to their body
and then when doll manufacturers figured
this out
they started making all dolls for kids
with these huge heads
and it was oh isn't that cute it's that
cute so
uh fascinating uh steve gould we he's
sorely missed on the landscape of of
biologist
so irene how many how many markers
coming
out of homo erectus can we identify
that enabled empowered them to become
good runners
so based on the article by dennis
bramble and dan lieberman
and actually titled born to run there
were 26
markers of endurance running and the
nuke ligament is one because it keeps
your head from bobbing
but the medial longitudinal arch is
another one because it helps to
attenuate the loads when you run
larger joint surfaces because the forces
are twice
that in running than in walking a long
achilles tendon because you need to be
able to store and release energy
so these are just some of the markers of
endurance running that really
demonstrate that we needed we evolved
for running they optimized us for
running just to be clear when you say
store energy you don't mean for long
term
effect you mean store it the way you
stretch a rubber band it's stored and
then you let it go and it snaps back
exactly right okay so an immediate
return
immediate return of energy that you
don't lose uh in in in some other way
okay so our ancestors had it they were
all they were pre
uh we we we had good ancestors for this
it's not
it's not a weird fact that we have
running contests
and running is a part of our culture
because it's a part of our past
before we extol the virtues of humans
running
aren't we slower than practically every
four-footed
creature that's out there right they're
i mean seriously the only
only turtles look at us and go god i
wish i had an achilles tendon
right if only i had an achilles tendon
or a new leg
yeah you try carrying your house on your
back
homo sapiens you think you're slow
turtles will totally go all up in your
face about that so
you know i don't you know so maybe we're
better runners than we would have
otherwise been as primates
but in the animal kingdom i think
other especially the four li four-legged
felines i think they pity us
really yeah so we are among the slowest
for sure but we have
the ability to run for very long
distances
and that was important for us for
survival because
it we we our brains were getting bigger
and we needed protein
at a time before we had projectiles like
spears and those kinds of
of tools and so we had to carve a kudu
out of the herd and run them to
exhaustion
and then we would club them to death wow
nice i gotta tell you that sounds like a
party
it sure does never have one so finally
something evolutionary that humans have
an advantage
physically over over other other animals
you know so so none of them were wearing
shoes so i had i had to ask chris i said
you know chris why do we wear running
shoes at all i asked him this just let's
see what he tells us i think the reason
why
we wear shoes is because in the 1970s
someone thought it'd be really cool to
sell people a bunch of shoes
running shoes that's when it took off
the 1970s that's right you know what's
fascinating neil is if you look at a
running shoe
prior to the early 70s you basically
take the top off and it's a sandal
you know the early running shoes like
your father wore they're basically
sandals with a little top on top for
laces
you know that's interesting you you
point that out because my father
uh he showed me his track shoes one day
when we went to the track my father used
to run track
and long enough he didn't in in high
school and college
and then he continued outside of school
and while we
my brother and sister and i were born so
i got to see sort of the tail end of
that
and i saw she pulled his shoes out of
the trunk and they were as light as a
feather
there wasn't all this extra rubber and
texture and healed it was like hardly
anything covering his foot
and this is this is old school now i'm
talking right so what what happened in
the 1970s was it just marketing those
early running shoes because they looked
like nothing
there was nothing to modify you know a
running sandal uh
it will last you a lifetime there's
nothing to sell and so in the 1970s what
happens you have bill bowerman who was a
coach at the university of oregon
teaming up with one of his runners phil
knights and they thought well
i can't really sell a sandal but what if
we put it
in right but what if what if we put a
swoosh on the side
what if we put a waffle sole on it what
if and they just started adding
sales gimmickry to this very very simple
device
over and over again that's why every six
months you go to the running shoe store
hey i want that shoe i got last month
and last year worked great now sorry
that's gone
here's a brand new one that you have to
buy is 150
and this was born nike yeah yeah so this
is it
basically what it came down to is there
was nothing to sell
with a simple sandal but if you tell
people hey if you don't buy these shoes
you're gonna get injured that's a real
motivator man that's like mafia based uh
motivation
you know if you don't do this thing
you're gonna get hurt we're gonna take
out your knees
right we're gonna take out your knees
that's that's the running shoe
industry's whole promise
either by the show we'll take out your
knees so i i mean
is is chris right about the running do
you agree with that
that perspective this 50 years of being
sold a product that we really don't
need gangs gangster running gangster
yeah yeah
gangsta you know i i love chris
mcdougall let me just say that but i
think this is a place where we
have a slightly different perspective so
i have spoken with
jeff johnson who was with nike back in
the day
um and when when in those very early
days
and what happened is that in the early
70s we had the running boom
right and a bunch of people who were not
trained
they're probably more fit than you and i
are today but they were
they were untrained most of people
running were running and running clubs
or in collegiate teams
and they started to run and these are
people who were walking around in shoes
that had maybe two inch
heels on them just normal shoes now
you're putting them into a racing flat
so now you're increasing the load on the
achilles
and you and they ended up with some
problems and so
what happened is they that nike actually
brought some sport podiatrists in
who saw a lot of these injuries and
these in these new runners
and asked them what is it and and they
came up with a number of different
changes to the shoe
and this is what this is this is what
jeff told me so
by adding a heel to toe drop you unload
that achilles so that's one way of
adapting the shoe to these individuals
who are not used to
landing on a flat surface then the
podiatrist also felt that
they were landing hard and they had a
lot of pronatory problems so they
started to add cushioning
and they started to add motion control
and then it became
more and more and more and more and so
my view of this is that the running shoe
companies rather than have the runners
adapt to the sport
which is what everyone did in the past
they took the shoe
and adapted it to the runner and ended
up actually i think doing more harm than
good
wow so doctor is it as simple as playing
on our fear of getting
sports running related injuries that
these empires have been built and they
are empires they're
global empires fear is quite the
motivator in all things
in everything the problem is that there
haven't been
a i'm not going to say any because maybe
there's one or two but there's
very few studies that show that these
shoes have reduced running injuries
and even today when you look at the
epidemiological studies
running injuries have not reduced they
have not been on the decline
if you put into pubmed a search
for running injuries there's almost
nothing prior to 1970.
everything starts at about 1970 and has
just continued to increase in terms of
reports of running injuries yeah but but
why
but why are the shoes so comfy when you
try them on
they're like you're putting on pillows
because you they're they're like the
barca lounger
same thing you just want to get in there
and sit and be comfy but
you know comfortable is and i'm not
saying we should never do that
and we should only you know squat and go
back to caves
but just keep in mind that when you are
doing that
you are not using the muscles of your
core and your back
um it really de conditioned you
it's so funny that you actually
mentioned squat because that is another
thing
that um is a recent invention in human
history
is you know sitting down and sitting
down for long periods of time
this is not something that we have done
throughout history
you don't find chairs no wait wait wait
chuck we adapted
that's why we have butt cheeks okay
those are our cushions
for sitting we've i think that's all
been taken care of
in the last couple years no no
the butt cheeks were not designed so as
you could sit on a rock
for an hour or two yeah they're actually
an integrity
before we go to break okay so the butt
cheeks are actually
we needed larger glutes when we ran the
gluteus maximus became much
broader and because now you're coming
and you're landing on one foot with two
and a half to three times your body
weight
you need that stabilization so those
butt cheeks i tell my husband that they
go honey this is why i have this gluteus
but basically those butt cheeks are are
really to help us to stabilize and
damn i i'd like my hypothesis better
i like my we evolved to have butt cheeks
so that we could one day have rap
videos
so that was the evolutionary driver the
the need for rap videos
okay all right we're gonna take a quick
break and when we come back
we're gonna talk more with irene davis
and chris mcdougall
on the biomechanics of running and
in particular technique when star talk
returns
we're back star talk sports edition i'm
with chuck nice and
gary o'reilly you're my peeps dudes
all right and today we're talking about
running running technique the
biomechanics of running
and we're wrapping it around my
interview with best-selling author and
runner himself
journalist chris mcdougall and the
we since we don't have the academic
expertise here we brought in
irene davis from the department of
physical medicine at the harvard medical
school
so irene are you based up in boston at
mass general is that where that happens
i'm i'm based out of spaulding yes in
boston in cambridge
okay in cambridge okay that's spalding
center that we introduced at the
beginning you know we've been buying
ever more sophisticated
running shoes for decades do we need
them
or do we need to change the way we run
he gleaned insight
from studying a group of people in
mexico
in his journalistic voyages to
understand
running let's check it out i would try
to run to get in shape i would get
injured doctors have said your body
isn't designed for this you're too big
the impact's bad
then they're going to have the copper
canyon copper cannon in mexico where you
find the
the taharah tribe exactly yes yeah
so i'm down there and i think i'm going
to find a group of people that are um
genetically predisposed to this but what
i also find is a guy
who looks just like me he's my same
height he's my same
shoe size and when he came down to the
copper canyon 15 years earlier
he had also been chronically injured a
guy named micah true
and at the point i met him after 15
years of running with tatar umara this
guy is just
cruising for 50 miles at a time and what
he told me is it ain't the shoes
it's not the genetics it's how you run
and he taught me a different running
style
and the thing about it was it all hinged
on the lack of footwear
the less obstruction i had between my
foot in the ground
the better and more injury free i became
so
all right so let me praise what you said
and then criticize what you said
so if this is the case then the less
footwear the better
and everyone should be running in bare
feet but
we have like cement roads and asphalt
and dog poop and you know
so so shouldn't some protection of the
foot
be in order here exactly protection but
not correction
your dad had protection we have
correction we have
four years of podiatry school is somehow
supposed to trump two million years of
evolution
so someone gets an idea like hey let's
put a wedge in it it'll help it doesn't
help
so why so tell me now i mean we're
dancing around this
this blunt question why is barefoot
better than a shoe why isn't the shoe
supplementing what you have to make
your running stride better rather than
supplanting what you have
making it worse the reason why
is because it doesn't sell that
answer is too easy i want a more
complicated answer
all right i'll give you more complicated
answer then okay
because when most people start to run
the first thing they do is walk
you walk first when you try on a pair of
running shoes in a store there's not
room for you to go running back and
forth so you're walking
and so what they did was they stuck a
big cushioned heel
underneath your foot because that's very
comfortable for walking so what they did
was
they took a shoe that's really designed
for walking
and they market it as a running shoe and
that's basically the problem it's the
big fat heel
so so irene are we just trying to
retrofit evolution
i mean what of the notion that yeah
we've been doing it for you know ten
thousand years
the fifty thousand years hundred
thousand years and now we're claiming
something's wrong with it
but what's also true is back then people
didn't really live much past
30. so i kind of like modern technology
and what it has done
for civilization even in spite of where
we
landed on the evolutionary arc so
we have where do you land in all of this
well i think
i think it's very difficult right this
moment for someone to just
immediately go back to not wearing shoes
because over the past
50 or 60 years we have deconditioned our
feet and now our feet
need it because our feet are unable to
cushion our feet are unable
to support themselves well when you run
if you took someone who runs in a modern
day cushioned supportive shoe
and put them into a minimal shoe or have
them run barefoot i guarantee you
and have them run their normal miles i
guarantee you it's guaranteed
they're going to get injured so that's
the problem is people have become
comfortable
and in order to move away from it it
takes a lot of time
and patience and a lot of people don't
have that time and patience
but i think if we had not accommodated
the shoe to the runner and
actually tried to get the runners to
accommodate to the sport
and that we didn't go if we didn't
develop these cushioned
and supportive shoes we wouldn't have
the musculoskeletal
injuries that we have today that is my
hypothesis
why didn't you push back on all this
when these shoes started rising up it's
your fault
do you want to know the truth please
because okay
so you know but when i started it's all
about the truth on this show
all right good so 25 years ago when i
was getting out of pt's phd my phd and
and uh and i really believed that there
were some feet
that actually could not tolerate the
loads of walking and running and they
needed orthotics and i became
the orthotic specialist in the in
at delaware at the in the department of
physical therapy just to be clear
orthotics means supplements to your feet
for whatever reason
yeah right and i was i was promoting
motion control and cushioned shoes and i
was in that mindset
so i didn't push back on it and it was
kind of an
aha moment for me it was sort of i
caught a perfect storm
of some research that came came around
it was chris's book
that made me think a little bit
differently but i was also my research
showing that when people land on their
heels they have big they
get impacts ground reaction force
impacts that are not there when you land
on the ball of your foot and when you're
barefoot
you land on the ball your foot so all of
this kind of came together
and slowly changed my thinking well my
my father who
ran track he used to run on his toes
people commented he was he was swift as
the wind
and you watch him is like is he running
or is he floating you know
you would ask that i was going to say
that when you look at different styles
of running that's
that was a movement a few years ago that
really
took flight excuse the terminology but
uh where staying on the balls
of your feet the entire time that you're
in your during your run was supposed to
be
a healthier and less degenerative
means of establishing a running regimen
is that the case or was that just
another
kind of marketing trickery type deal
again i go back to the mismatch theory
of evolution i think that
landing on the ball of the foot is the
way that we were adapted to run
and we know that because if you studies
have shown that the less
time people spend in footwear the more
tendency they have to run on the ball of
their foot
it's that cushioned heel that chris
referred to that causes people to land
on their heel because they can
but when you land on your heel you get
this impact
transient that your body experiences you
don't even really feel it
but it's there and research has shown
that it's related to injuries
we'll talk about a three-hour experiment
the new york city marathon
run every year in november i think it
was it was postponed from
covid but it's an annual tradition i
think it's the largest marathon in the
world
more than 30 000 people compete you just
sit there and watch how everybody's
running
and nobody's running the same way as
anybody else is running
and they can't all be right however
if you look at cross-country runners
they all have the same form
so okay with that well let's go to my
next clip with chris mcdougall and see
where that goes check it out
you could universalize all those 30 000
runners in like one second
if at the starting line you said
everybody take your shoes off
and run in place and then
and then and then run in place now when
you run in place and you can do this
experiment yourself neil
um if you take off your shoes and you
just run
in place in your apartments what you're
going to find is you're going to have to
keep your back straight because if
you're slumping forward you're going to
move forward
you're going to have to land on your
forefoot because you can't run in place
and land on your heels it doesn't work
and that's basically it there's a guy
who created a thing called the 100 up
back in the 1800s this was a carpenter's
apprentice who had to work inside
and he competed in track events on the
weekend so he invented the hundred up
and the hundred up is if i run in place
for a hundred strides
and don't move forward then i did a
perfect repetition and what he found is
just by trying to do a hundred strides
running in place in his bare feet
he was able to develop perfect running
form and that's basically what it comes
down to is so anybody wants to change
their running form
take off your shoes run in place and you
will automatically start to mimic
how the tatumata run people who
described my father's
running gate they said it was like a
gazelle uh he had very long stride but
he also
basically ran on his on his on the balls
of his feet
off of his toes and that gave him a
particular
uh spring and mobility to
to his his running style and the gate
so uh that's that's fascinating all
right so now you now you're challenging
me now
i really gotta do this now why are you
doing this to me i was perfectly happy
on the couch
now i got to run and barefoot around the
block
on the cement and all right if
something bad happens i'm coming for you
i just want you to know so irene
is there an ideal surface on which to
run
because you haven't you you've been
suspiciously ignoring
whether running on spikes or grass or
tartan track
what you want to run barefoot but on
what surface does it matter
so that's a really good question um we
what's amazing
is that we were adapted to run on many
different surfaces so the tama humada
think about it they're running in the
copper canyons of mexico
they're running on some hard rock
they're running on dirt
we run in grass and what happens is you
adjust automatically your leg spring
to the surface that you come in contact
with so if you come in contact with a
hard surface
you make your leg spring more compliant
when you come in contact with a soft
surface like sand
or grass you make your legs stiffer so
you can adjust
your stiffness to the surface that you
come in contact with
wow so our brains are like the computer
chips in our cars for limited slip
differential
no matter terrain it doesn't matter the
terrain yeah i love that
yeah but does it have positive
if there is a correct running technique
we're all different shapes and sizes
all four of us are a different shape so
can we just
give that's the correct technique you do
it but you're different to you
and you're different to her and he's
different to me so
is there the correct technique and the
correct technique only or do we have
some
area that we have to change in
developing look i
we all are different we all are unique
we're all going to move differently
but there are some fundamentals about
the way that we move
and i'm going to make an argument about
our structure
that actually suggests that we really
are adapted to land on the ball of our
foot
so let me just give you a couple of
examples our heel pad
there have been studies have shown that
when you apply a
force a load to the heel pad you hit
your pain pressure threshold
at the point the force exceeds the
forces of walking
what that means is your heel pad is
there designed to attenuate the loads of
walking
not running the stiffness of the
forefoot pad
is higher than the stiffness of the heel
pad
meaning that it's better able to dampen
the loads of landing
so those are just two examples the
achilles tendon
is there it developed in order to be
able to
store and release energy and you have a
much larger calf
than you do in anterior tip muscles so
those are just some examples
that show that really we were adapted to
and if you look at
i get in this argument a lot with my
colleagues because
95 percent of modern runners who wear
modern shoes are rarefor strikers and
they say to me irene then that's normal
and i say no i think it's abby normal i
don't think that's normal i think that
we are maladapting and we really were
adapted to run this way and we did for
most of our evolutionary history if you
look at ancient
pictures of vases greek vases and
figures
it portrays man running on the ball of
his foot
if you look at the boston dynamic robot
named atlas
who's a very cool he can do parkour he
can dance
um he's awesome um but they're all
creepy these that
these are creepy robots when they no you
gotta see he's so cool though
he's huge he's so human let's just say
now until we be
they become our overlords okay but but
he runs on the ball of his foot and so
you're they're not going to design
something that's not efficient so
they're just there's so many
so many indicators to me that this is
the way we were adapted to the run the
way we were meant to run
and you know we may get into talking
about injuries at some point but but i
can
can give you biomechanical examples of
how it can reduce risks for injuries as
well
i'll say this as you were making that
explanation which was uh
um quite specific thank you it was very
tight
it was a very tight explanation in my
mind i was picturing a person running
and what what struck me was the heel
strike method
gives you an extra unnecessary movement
in running you strike your heel then the
rest of the foot comes down
then there's a return of energy the
other way
you eliminate that extra movement the
uh the ball of your foot comes down and
a spring
action actually happens eliminating that
extra movement
and then there's a more immediate return
of
energy so it makes sense why so many
people
one of my close friends just had this
surgery they had to take a tendon from
another part of her body
and replace her achilles tendon because
she's addicted to running
and ran her achilles tendon into
oblivion so i mean what you say just
makes absolute perfect sense chuck you
should come work for us
national running center
i'd like to see that happen
today in the news the spalding center
closed down
any time so doctor just not the
efficiency of running
right because we've sort of identified
earlier in the show that we're not the
fastest species
um but we are able to run these long
distances we're built for efficiency but
that efficiency came with a package of
injury prevention am i am i getting that
right
is that the way it's supposed to work
well i mean
if we were and if we were meant to run
and we had to run for survival it
doesn't make sense
that we would that 50 of us would get
injured in a given year
which is on average so i i don't think
that we were designed to get injured i
think we were designed to be able to run
without injury now there's it's not so
simple you know i don't think we were
designed
to run you know even 26 miles in a
straight line on hard surfaces
we ran on multiple surfaces we ran in
many directions
our ancestors did with persistence
hunting
and that varies the load that the body
experiences and that helps to reduce the
risk of injury
but having said that i still think that
the injury rate is much higher than it
should be
based on the fact that we evolved to run
so if i if i run correctly with the
correct technique in my mind i will then
strengthen i can't strengthen the
ligament can i it's a ligaments the
ligament
but i can strengthen the muscles yeah
around the length
so i will actually have a stronger and
i'll call it healthier foot
where else does this develop from
the foot through the achilles through
the calf muscles where else
um the biggest change the biggest change
in load when you go from a rear foot to
a forefoot strike
is from the knee down and we do know
that habitual forefoot strikers
have stronger stiffer and you want a
stiff tendon because
they store and release that immediate
energy quicker they have stronger
stiffer tendons
because they land on the ball of their
foot and they're constantly
strengthening them
your arch muscles have greater demand
put on them when you're landing on the
ball of your foot
greater demand means that over time
they're going to get stronger
so clearly this kind of a pattern in the
beginning
transitioning those are the areas that
can get injured because you're not
accommodated to it so calf
arch sometimes metatarsals but if you
take it slow and transition slowly
then you can t you can train the body to
adapt to that load and then those
tissues
will actually get stronger i mean i just
realized something
correct me if i'm wrong almost all
fast running four-legged animals
their vertebrates their heel
never touches the ground because it
evolved up higher up
on their leg aren't they basically
running on their toes like horses
and and the big feline uh
you know lions and tigers isn't that am
i correct about i think i'm correct
you are yes you are now we
just said forget the heel i'm not even
going there i don't think you want to do
that i just want to make that point we i
think that
we do want to come down and land on the
heel and then come back up again
you don't want to land on the ball of
the foot and keep the heel up that helps
to
to actually give that calf a break and
let you go through the full range of
motion but
you're right a lot of the animal kingdom
does not land on their heel at all
right right and their legs bend like our
elbows
so what's up with us there no
portions of the long bones are different
so it looks it looks freakier
we've got to take a quick break but when
we come back let's talk we'll spend some
time
chewing the fat and exploring
whether we can out engineer evolution
itself
in human performance when star talk
sports edition returns
we're back star talk sports edition got
chuck nice co-host chuck you're tweeting
at chuck nice comic
yes sir thank you everyone check that
out and gary
o'reilly hey looking at my three left
feet
three left feet yes i gotta sort of
remember that
yeah that's that's a challenge for the
doctor by the way okay one day
you'll explain we've got uh with me as
our in
studio academic expert uh professor
dr irene davis i irene
do you are you active in social media i
am
irene s davis easy
on twitter twitter very good right very
good okay
uh we're gonna find you there and you're
an expert on all things feet
so uh why don't we go straight into my
final clip with
chris mcdougall um because we always
seem to be
striving to reaching for the next bit of
technology to improve
our performance and either by
engineering or by design and
are we looking in the right place for
our answers i brought that up with chris
let's check out his reply
i think there's a natural ancestral pull
you know that early humans if you saw
something new interesting
or more effective you would be you
gravitate toward that's a reason why
we went from spears to bows and arrows
the better technology is going to give
you an evolutionary advantage that's
fantastic
the problem is that's so hard grained in
our minds we can't stop
shopping you know we keep looking for
the thing that's going to be better
and we just need to cycle back every
once in a while and just say hey
what has worked for two million years as
opposed to 10 years
you know you look at like sports drinks
you got to have the special sport drinks
in the bottle
dude a cup of water is all you need a
little water a little salt
you're good to go and i said that's
basically what it comes down to is
rather than being sold
look back as to what you can actually
practice what behavior can you change
that will provide the difference
so you're a living nightmare of at least
a dozen different companies
who want you to buy their products yeah
i think so especially when it comes to
things like running
uh you're you're pre-equipped with
everything you need so so i mean what
what advice do you have for parents who
want to do right by their kids are you
just going to send them off barefoot
what are you going to do you know it's
such a good question because i think the
holy grail
to um reducing musculoskeletal injuries
is starting with kids
i think that if we put our kids i have
grandkids
and my grandkids are in minimal shoes i
buy the minimal shoes all the time when
they grow out of them i buy a new pair
because i think if you teach if you put
them in minimal shoes
their feet will get stronger they'll
develop the the kind of lower extremity
that we evolved to have
and they're going to be much much less
likely to land on their heel
when they go to run they're going to be
more likely and studies have shown this
to land on the ball of their foot i
would i would tell them to let their
kids be barefoot
i mean i used to step in dog poop and
you know when i was a kid i spent a lot
of time barefoot and i think kids
should be allowed to have that sensory
input so yes
let kids go barefoot and try to keep
them in minimal shoes and not
go don't be don't be tempted to go to
the
the highly cushioned and highly
supportive shoes
chuck how do you think that goes over in
elementary school hey so tell us about
your grandmother
oh she she told me to step in dog poop
and uh
come on next i need more sensory input
so excuse me what's that on your foot
sensory input thank you
okay which big deal okay got a problem
with that
you got a problem go sit over there on
your own
yeah so let me ask you this uh dr davis
i have fallen arches
i passed that on to my children is that
a problem is there anything that can be
done to correct that i have a seven year
old so
is it too late um when in your
development
when in your development is it too late
or is it ever
so i i mean we all have different
structure not everybody has perfect
arches
and and i think probably from an
evolutionary standpoint that was the
case as well
there's a lot of variation in our
anatomical structure
that doesn't mean that you can't
strengthen your arch muscles
and and once you once your ligaments are
stretched out
you can't really shorten them short of
surgery but you can train the muscles
to hold up that arch and so i do think
that there is the
ability for kids to develop that and
even adults
we work with adults with flat fee and
we've gotten people to actually get rid
of their orthotics and use the muscles
rather than the insoles to actually
support their arch
so there's hope look at that that's i've
never even heard of that before that's
amazing
yep and let me just say i like i said i
was born with flat feet had flat feet my
whole life
and and it's so flat it goes it comes
out the other way he's got concave feet
i come out of the shower bigfoot just
flat
flap down duck flap and i could outrun
everybody uh when i was growing up so
just what i talked to
i'd hear you coming though
[Laughter]
excuse me who's applauding right now who
is applauding oh wait
that's just me flapping my way down the
track so gary
how does all this apply to soccer you
know when you're running up and down a
soccer field
any questions you have for irene that
comes from that angle
well because we we need i mean our human
hand is so dexterous
but our foot has nothing like that
mobility
but we caress a soccer ball with our
foot we need to move it we need to do
certain things with it
and the ability to have not a completely
loose ankle and foot would be
really advantageous if you could sort of
develop that flexibility in the foot
or are we kind of kidding myself with
that
no i i agree i think you know running is
the easiest case to make for minimal
footwear because
our feet were designed to run although
soccer
people ask me about basketball and
skiing and other sports but soccer
really is running
and it's running in multi-directions
there are there are
still communities that play soccer
barefoot
um and so i think i think soccer could
also fit into this
um same kind of paradigm yeah through
the show we've talked about how
we've got running shoes that have been
built
constructed engineered are we are we
trying to out
engineer the human body and it's
i mean the cure you've talked about for
fallen arches is a natural thing you are
strengthening a muscle by
bringing in your toes and developing
certain areas
are we really just out engineering
our foot i don't think you can now
engineer mother nature
i think we need to really rely on mother
nature and
there are caveats to this you know if
somebody doesn't have the ability
as long as those muscles are not
paralyzed they can get stronger
but if you have someone that has a
developmental disability cerebral palsy
maybe
a stroke or you know diabetes where they
don't have good sensation there are lots
of
applications to correct as as chris said
but the large majority of people that
are in these shoes have normal
intact musculoskeletal systems and those
are the people who i think
we need to let mother nature do it's
it's it's
it's work yeah i suffer from something
called chiptitus
it's where you lay on the couch and eat
chips
all right so doctor no that's potato
chip items oh yes oh sorry
oh that's a specific variety i think
there's a shoe for that
yeah yes and my father said it goes in a
particular place
so okay doctor i mean with this stolen
the virtues of
running in minimal shoes or barefoot
in 10 years time are we all going to be
running
in barefoot or with minimal shoes or or
is it just you know the guys who run
barefoot are going to do it at midnight
when no one's watching
well i mean i can tell you what i hope i
hope that this catches on i think that
more and more parents are not putting
their kids into those really rigid shoes
that
we used to put our kids in and i was in
as a child
what was that about you know remember
those yes those little frankenstein
shows
they were awful and the kids would
couldn't walk you know exactly
so they're now putting kids in soft
shoes and now
a number of podiatrists that i know are
not putting people in foot orthotics
for their whole life just temporarily so
i think that the pendulum's swinging a
little bit
and i hope i just hope that with more
evidence
and you know more and more of these
kinds of shows where people listen
because when i talk people go wow i
never thought about it that way
you know you wouldn't put a neck brace
on your on your neck for life
because you wouldn't be able to hold
your head up and yet we put these
supportive shoes and orthotics in our in
our shoes
for life and we don't think another
thing about it so if we all do this
we're going to put you out of a job
that's okay okay so so what about the
the the feet shoes do you guys know what
i'm talking about
with you with i see some people at the
gym wearing these
i love those and uh you know they look
weird
but is there any benefit to them because
i'm not gonna make fun of those people
if there's a benefit
but if there's not a benefit you need to
take your planet of the apes butt
and take those shoes off man wait wait
let me lead into that let me add to
chuck's question because no time so far
have you
spoken to the consequences to your
skin on the bottom of your feet for
having your body weight slammed down on
pavement or anything else
all this time so what i'm wondering is
whether this shoes that chuck is
referring to
which is just basically a covering of
your foot
that highlights each of your toes it's
kind of cute a little creepy but cute
when you see it
is that really just replacing your skin
so that you don't have skin injuries
because otherwise it's clearly not
structural right chuck i mean
exactly it looks like a glove for your
foot it is a glove for your foot and
in all minimal shoes i i put those fight
they're called five fingers
and they've got individual pockets but
they're really not that much different
than a minimal shoe a minimal shoe
is a shoe that has a very thin outer
sole
maybe a canvas type of top one that you
can roll up and put in your pocket
right that's some that is a minimal shoe
just like the five fingers so the five
fingers are a minimal shoe
some people like the individual movement
of the toes other people find it a
little uncomfortable because
their toes are you know toes are kind of
weird as you know and they don't always
fit in the pockets well
that you have to break them in i've had
them and you do have to break them in
but
they're not the only kind of minimal
shoe a minimal shoe could be something
you get at target for ten dollars a pair
of white cheap canvas shoes
i mean that's what a minimal shoe is oh
i'm so happy to hear
that but did jesus have minimal shoes he
would probably have just these samples
without a doubt
no doubt i guess you're not a big fan of
these carbon fiber
shoes that got the plates in them that
are going to reduce running times
all right so well you know i here's some
here's my feeling
about that so clearly these shoes have
been shown to increase performance
or reduce running time well just a quick
so gary are they shoes that have
that store energy better than your feet
would and so you get it all back yeah so
they have carbon fiber
fight fiber can i speak english no um
they have carbon fiber plates in them
small little plates and the whole idea
is to return energy
and for an elite marathon runner all you
need is a three or four percent
kick yeah or less you're gone
say here's one percent at one percent
get you 10 minutes
so i mean are you all for this or not
well you know so they're called the four
percent shoe because that was the
average
improvement that they saw with these
shoes and and to be honest it's more in
the foam gary
than in the plates plates provide
rigidity but they don't have as much
energy return as this special foam
of course the foam gets worn out pretty
quickly
um so the problem that i see with it is
that
i believe in purity i want the person
who's up on that podium to be up on that
podium because of their own
ability and not because they have
footwear that's you know
giving them spring so let's have people
run on springs you know
um i know and i know that they're
they're struggling with this
you know world athletics is struggling
with this they're struggling with this
because
you know and the other problem with this
is that not everybody can wear them
you know nike's the one that have these
shoes but not everyone's sponsored by
nike so then you have a disadvantage and
i don't know i just um i'd rather go
back to just
flats racing flats like we had before in
the 60s and early 70s
and let the person's ability be what
puts them up on the podium that's my
feeling
now if i were a high level elite runner
i'd probably love those shoes
yeah especially the idea of running on
springs
okay i won the boston marathon in the
fastest time ever
too bad i was on a pogo stick you know
the pogo gotta start the pogo pogo is
first
if we do all convert to barefoot running
um and
you your clinical aspect of things we'll
be probably able to answer this
what sort of percentage reduction and
injuries would we see
so all right that's a really good
question first of all i'm not advocating
everybody go out and run barefoot
because i think that people
especially if you're running a race you
don't want to cut your foot you can cut
your foot you expose it
right so there are times when you want
to protect your feet so
and minimal shoes and barefoot running
are very similar they're not the same
you don't get the same sensory input you
don't get that dog poop between your
toes
but they but the mechanics are very
similar
between barefoot and minimal shoes
that's what you're after here
and i'm really so i'm really i'm really
proposing that people go to footwear
that just basically protects and doesn't
correct as chris says
how much will that reduce injuries it's
really hard to say
i think it will significantly reduce
injuries we know that when you run on
the ball of your foot
it reduces the load at the knee and the
most common
running related injury is at the knee we
know that when you run on the ball of
your foot
it reduces the load to the anterior
compartment the lower leg the front of
your lower leg
that is where shin splints occur that is
also where anterior compartment syndrome
occurs where you get high pressure
so i know that that's going to be
reduced i know that it strengthens the
achilles tendon so i believe that
there's a 52 percent likelihood of
achilles tendinitis in
males over the course of their running
history their running career
so i i know that that's going to be
reduced so i really believe
that these kinds of of muscular skeletal
injuries are very common
are going to be reduced when you when
you when you reduce the impacts
and you run in a way that we're adapted
to run man i feel like taking off my
shoes now
i was going to say at the least
everybody especially if you're a dog
owner
get out there and get some sensory input
but
you still can't you can't shake the
sensory he's locked on that
you know i'd like to ask you guys all to
take your shoes off and see if you can
spread your toes
because um gary you said you know your
hands have this mobility but your feet
don't but
you know what you have every single
muscle in your
foot that you have in your hands and
you're supposed to be able to spread
your toes
oh i used to pick stuff up with my toes
all the time well i think it was just
too lazy to bend over
and grab it with my hand so but then you
have to be able to lift your leg up high
enough to then reach it
yeah so you need a double thing going on
there but i have pretty
i have pretty dexter dec deck is that
the word
dexterous toads myself i don't mean to
brag or anything
you just did yeah i just i'm pretty sure
my toe dexterity is suffering quite a
bit
so yeah maybe i'm going to start working
on that you should work on it
yeah i'm i'm more i'm more concerned
about the sprains in my ankles
so you've got many more years to keep
this movement
uh keep a force behind this movement
yeah and we'd be delighted to sort of
check back in with you
to see get sort of an update well i
really appreciate you
giving air time to this particular topic
because i think it's really important
very very cool all right dr irene davis
from the harvard medical school thanks
for joining
star talk and gary always good to have
you here
pleasure neil thank you all right chuck
always a pleasure
all right and um i don't want to smell
your feet where
whether or not you've stepped in poop
okay oh well okay
all right now well i'm disappointed
now what am i going to get you for
christmas
[Laughter]
all right this has been star talk sports
edition all about defeat
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]